sur la relation des gens et l'argent je
peux vous déranger 2000 combien vous
gagnez par mois un sas et
[Musique]
là c'est vraiment la relation des gens
combien puisque tout net par mois à
chypre au bar beaucoup
et eau pour interroger les gens du rpt
leur relation à l'argent
mais est ce que vous gagnez par mois
c'est un tabou
j'ai
alors fait rien vous n'avez vous pas oui
mais je comprends que les gens aient pas
envie de parler de cela parce que
l'argent c'est toujours source de
problèmes et quand on dit sont celles-là
on dit toujours oui en france on aime à
l'aise avec l'argent je pense que tout
le monde est mal à l'aise avec l'argent
prenez l'exemple ici on a tous des
salaires différents je pense que si
certains apprenez les salaires des
autres en disant à poste égal même si
les inégalités sont peut-être justifiée
mais on serait forcément peut-être
envieux jaloux on comprendrait pas donc
je comprends qu'on ne donne pas son
salaire c'est toujours source de
problèmes je pense que on est dans une
société où on est persuadé que si tu
gagnes plus que l'autre tu es mieux
c'est pas le salaire qui fait la
réussite c'est vraiment que la
réalisation de soi c'est comment tu es
et ce que tu as voulu faire parfois les
gens qui ont choisi un métier comme
médecin dix ans d'études ils vont gagner
beaucoup moins d'argent qu'à la télé
mais ils ont fait ce choix là
heureusement que le salaire n'est pas un
signe de réussite pour moi je ne pense
pas c'est du confort mais c'est pas un
signe de réussite castaldi moins 5000
j'ai dit il ya dix ans j'ai fait
l'erreur de dire combien je bénis par
mois et je les pays tenez conviendrait
vieillit comme à l'écrit gelé n'y ait
plus de 150000 euros par mois par mois
ça merde à moi à moi à moi oui bravo
arrive ça va par mois en tapas
150 blessés mais c'était beaucoup
d'argent ça marche entre 50000 euros par
mois ouais ouais c'est que vous habitiez
chez lui oui tout à fait dès qu'il a
arrêté chez party
c'est pas voulu assister à la deschamps
c'était trop dur c'était un ami et vous
alors béatrice et elle essayait
occasions des rennais
mais ça c'est pas du tout comme ici mais
je pense qu aux etats unis c'est
différent parce que les gens ont
l'impression d'avoir vraiment une
égalité des chances et c'est une
méritocratie et quand les gens
travaillent beaucoup ils ont
l'impression qu'ils peuvent vraiment y
arriver alors qu'en france il ya pas
forcément ceux cette même voie la plus
grosse somme que des deux chaises un
film sur ces sur une série oui
c'était donc par épisode
si je le dis
il va pasqua
ne vous a pas porté chance
combien
balle aurait
fait une fourchette
plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de dollars par
épisode par épisode attendu comme un
épisode mais combien entre 13 et 22
austin saison qu'on a plus de dix mille
neuf cent cinquante dollars cent mille
dollars 1 million $ plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de dollars par épisode et
ensuite il ya déjà des royalties etc
donc ça s'ajoute aux autres mais c'est
aux états unis s'est serré la
main il ya beaucoup d'appelés peu d'élus
et quand vous allez aux états unis que
vous rencontrez quelqu'un pour la
première fois au bout de la troisième
question il te demande combien tu gagnes
léo il te le disent et ils sont fiers de
te dire qu'ils gagnent tant est qu'ils
ont une super belle voiture en effet en
tout cas ici je gagne pas ça
il n'y aura jamais ça